Speaker 1: All right, let's get back to your calls
via Discord, find The David Pakman Show Discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord very, very
easy. It works beautifully. I mean, really, really
beautifully. Let's go. Oh, I'm told Nate from
Rhode Island now knows what to do to talk to me,
Nate from Rhode Island, you are on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, Dave in my mike was
muted last time. How are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well. Thank you.
Speaker 2: So I had a question. What is the
best way to oust mentioned in cinema apart
from voting them out at the next opportunity?
Speaker 1: Well, that's the only way, as far as
I know, you've got a vote. What what other ways
do you have in mind? I hope you're not talking
about like an assassination?
Speaker 2: No, no, no.
Speaker 1: How else do you get them out other
than them losing an election or retiring?
Speaker 2: I was curious, is there a
way to like like, I don't know if the
whole vote of no confidence thing
is actually a way to oust the man,
if that's just like a formal thing or.
Speaker 1: No, I think it's just a formality.
I mean, listen, here's here's the thing I think
Bill Share actually said it really, really well
this this applies more to mankind than to
cinema. It would be very hard to replace Manchin
with a more liberal Democrat in the Senate,
a deep red state in the Senate, right? So
without Manchin right now, Democrats don't even
have a majority, and Mitch McConnell prevents
all of the things we're talking about from even
being on the floor of the Senate. So really,
you've got to replace some Republicans with
Democrats. That actually is what needs to be done.
Manchin in West Virginia. I don't know. Like
if you managed to defeat him in a primary,
that person almost certainly loses the general
election. Yeah. So I just don't know. I mean, I I
I didn't overstate right after the November 2020
election, I said, Joe Manchin is going to be a
problem. And a lot of people wrote to me and they
said, Sir, you're overstating that. And I said,
Yeah. And it turned out that I and others were
right. But the solution isn't replace, you know,
get Manchin out and have a Republican, be in a
seat. It's we got to flip some Republican seats.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm hoping to
get more progressives in the
2022 midterms. Fingers crossed with that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there's we have I haven't
done a full breakdown of what's possible in
the Senate in twenty two. It's not impossible,
but it's going to be an uphill battle.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it makes sense. All
right. Thanks for the call, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. Thanks
for calling me. I should start calling people.
That's actually not a bad idea. I like that idea.